Stéphane Guillon
Stéphane Guillon pour sa revue de presse
de la semaine bonsoir
alors Stéphane
cette revue de presse de la semaine
on a été gâté quand même sur la fin oui
politique à l'UDF André Santini a été
suspendu c'est dangereux la dernière
chose suspendue chez Santini c'était son
balcon
le couple Bayrou à la côte un sondage
Ifop bah forcément par rapport au
Sarkozy madame Bayrou n'est jamais parti
par rapport au Hollande les bayrous
dorment ensemble et par rapport aux deux
Villiers aucun des 6 enfants Bayrou n'a
violé son frère
ça fait beaucoup
une info libération Sarkozy court après
les sportifs attention Nicolas a couru
après sa femme pendant un an il est très
en forme
écologie Dominique voynez s'est adressée
au chasseur je ne suis pas venu faire
une danse du ventre devant vous
heureusement
voilà qui montre son ventre si les gars
on leur fusil ils tirent la bécasse à
plume ça les excite
malgré le retrait de Hulot voanet
plafonne à 2%. c'est marrant on a beau
être écolo voisin candidate ça donne
envie de rouler en 4K
à Paris 7 heures de bouchon suite à un
accident sur le périphérique en vérité
c'est Bertrand Delanoë qui testait son
nouveau plan pour fluidifier par ici
un couloir de bus sur l'autoroute A10 ah
ça c'est une idée de la nouer rendre
l'autoroute piétonne
couloir de 30 mètres de large trottoir
géant pour la balade et piste cyclable à
contresens
[Rires]
Clint Eastwood reçoit la Légion
d'Honneur faut pas qu'il apprenne qu'on
l'avait filé à Maurice Papon parce que
l'inspecteur Harry quand on se paye sa
tête il sort son SMIC Wesson
indignation Papon enterré avec sa
médaille qu'est-ce que ça change de son
vivant la rosette ornait déjà une
pourriture
consolez-vous aucune fleur ne poussera
autour de sa tombe le Papon une variété
de fumier qui ne donne rien
[Applaudissements]
justice les couples gays interdit
d'adoption il y a des contradictions les
homosexuels ne peuvent pas adopter
d'enfants en revanche on peut très bien
adopter un futur homosexuel
vie sociale la grève des gardiens de
musique continue pourtant sur cette
photo on voit que certains ont repris le
travail
people Jean-Luc Delarue pète les plombs
dans un avion inquiétude à France 2 bah
ils ont viré Ardisson pour un type
d'animateur plus consensuel 6 mois plus
tard pendant un qui mord des stewards
l'autre qui veut castrer des Noirs
cela dit Sevran n'a jamais mordu un
steward au contraire
[Applaudissements]
résumons le Stewart tu peux le mordre tu
peux lui couper la [ __ ] tant que tu lui
dis pas je vais voter Bayrou France 2
passe les ponts
Le Figaro consacre un article sur la
peur des people en avion caprice cous et
morsure le plus élégant reste le prince
Albert qui pour conjurer sa peur se tape
une hôtesse aux toilettes
la marraine retrouvée de Michel
Polnareff
vous savez pas quand landau c'était
perdu
[Rires]
déclare ne l'écrivait surtout pas les
vins de deux par Dieu sont épouvantables
alors c'est vrai cela dit on peut les
boire en regardant l'île au trésor un
bon navet arrosé d'une piquer crotte
c'est top et on termine par notre coup
de cœur guitarlier Joséphine d'art
attendre un bébé
alors c'est elle qui est enceinte
et l'enfant s'appellera Antoine hommage
au travail de Frédéric Dard en hommage
au travail de Guy il aurait fallu
appeler le petit Marc Olivier Fogiel
c'est un coup à se faire casser la
gueule à la récré à la semaine prochaine
merci beaucoup merci et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu